qu'est ce que vous pensez des pdg pahud
et ça devrait dépasser ce genre de
questions j'ai pas sauf que ces lignes
je sais pas j'ai pas du tout du
carrelage
qu'est ce que vous pensez des [ __ ] dans
des zones aussi qu el sayed initiale ou
ses armes au vulgaire pour dire guen
pour le public un peu choqué ça termes
que j'emploie pas madame excusez moi les
animaux rigide et amis qui sont comme ça
il ya soixante dix ans que je suis dans
le portique jouer la salle est affectée
entendent y avait à carpiquet produits
les pour vous les acceptez vous les
comprenez je les accepte gilles comprend
certes bizarre comme question oui je les
comprends enfin je les comprends à quel
titre en fait d'aimer quelqu'un d'autre
ouais je les comprends vous les acceptez
vous les comprenez ben oui j'en ai dans
ma famille j'ai mon petit cousin donc
voilà comment jugez vous les hommes qui
aiment les hommes c'est pas normal c'est
un riche way attendu et l'amour aux
normes
comment vous jugez les hommes qui aiment
les hommes
moi je porte un jugement je suis pas
dieu donc pour moi un an c'est un homme
il fait sa vie comme il veut puis c'est
tout moi ce temps une femme pareille il
ya pas de jugement
c'est normal chacun aime qui m et c'est
pas la sexualité c'est de l'amour donc
voilà
[Musique]